non et puis à Paris Plage tu peux faire
des trucs que tu peux pas faire à la
merde d'ailleurs j'ai nagé avec des
poissons dans la Seine ah c'est super
agréable quand tu peux les toucher vu
qu'ils sont morts
et maintenant j'accueille Gaspard Proust
pour l'été de Gaspard
[Applaudissements]
PMA ou GPR
je vais le vendre après
c'est ta vie bon alors je suis je suis
pas parti
j'avais envie mais comme il y avait plus
de place au stage croisade en terrain
connu qu'organise Civitas à la Mecque
façon moi je vais pas les moyens en
revanche le mec à Bercy qui vient de me
redresser fiscalement bon séjour au
Seychelles monsieur
façon il faut être lucide en France on
bosse la moitié de l'année pour l'État
donc là depuis le 30 juin je suis passé
fonctionnaire du secteur privé
c'est le meilleur des deux mondes le
salaire du public avec l'insécurité du
privé
en gros j'ai l'impression d'être un flic
du quai des sorts Fèvre qui fait des
heures sup' comme vigueur de boîte à
Béziers
je trouve ça plutôt chouette quoi c'est
vrai que moi toute l'année je rêve de
ces délicieuses promiscuité des plages
c'est c'est le métro décapotable s'il y
a bien une chose que j'ai envie de
retrouver sur la Côte d'Azur c'est
l'ambiance de la ligne 13 avec des gens
à poil c'est vrai
mais l'été c'est aussi l'occasion de
penser aux autres quoi faut par exemple
moi je m'occupe un peu de mes
grands-parents là je les installe dans
une morgue
c'est super pratique parce que ça fait
deux coups en un quoi tu vois d'un côté
il fait froid et si jamais il décède ils
sont déjà sur place
pas de toute façon qu'est-ce qu'on
apprend en vacances qu'on aime rien
faire alors certains disent oui moi j'en
profite pour lire faut voir ce que les
gens lisent en vacances les vies Musso
pas encore tout ça des chefs dans
lesquels on entre avec autant de
facilité que dans une Allemande après le
passage des Russes
alors du coup je suis là à Paris quoi je
m'occupe comme je peux bon heureusement
il y a Paris Plage ça c'est génial
[ __ ] moi le béton
j'adore ça quoi c'est le souffle chaud
des bouches d'égout comme une caresse
sur la pauvreté restez coincée au péage
de l'autoroute du soleil
puis déjà il y a pas de chant des
cigales et ça c'est insupportable moi le
chant des cigales on dirait un troupeau
de lépreux qui se découpe la poêle au
Pinel tu vois un truc
voilà nature ça me fascine pas du tout
je vous dis direct vous êtes écho mais
franchement je trouve ça
parce que la nature je la trouve pas
sympathique vous voyez moi je trie mes
poubelles c'est pas pour ça que quand je
vais au ski j'ai une semaine de beau
temps
fire pour vider la tête je suis allé là
je fais des pâtés de sable pendant une
heure je me suis engueulé avec un gosse
qui voulait détruire mon château c'est
le gamin il me lance si tu me rends pas
mon truc j'appelle mes deux papa
tu peux faire des trucs que tu peux pas
faire à la mer d'ailleurs j'ai nagé avec
des poissons dans la Seine c'est super
agréable quoi tu peux les toucher vu
qu'ils sont morts
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dérivé à côté d'une carte pendant
trois heures entre le Pont des Arts et
Bir-Hakeim et j'avais l'impression de me
tirer la bourre avec Jean-Marc Ayrault
donc c'est un truc
moi je suis bien que sur les quêtes
façons là parce qu'en ville en été il y
a que des il y a que des touristes et
des pauvres parfois les deux ça
s'appelle un chinois
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont cons ces mecs on
s'en déconner sur le Champ de Mars il y
a un chinois qui me demande où est la
Tour Eiffel je dirais je suis désolé je
suis pas du 7e arrondissement
là je vais sortir un plan du métro SNCF
il doit être entre Valenciennes
enfin j'ai rien contre attention j'ai
rien contre ces gens-là mais ils sont
pas comme nous quoi je veux dire même
les Chinois est installés en France faut
reconnaître qu'ils sont très mal
intégrés et bossent tout le temps
il se croit en Allemagne
[Applaudissements]
c'est toujours les maghrébins qui
prennent c'est toujours les Maghrébins
alors qu'à bien des égards ils sont
beaucoup plus civilisés alors ok le
halal c'est pas un modèle d'homéopathie
bouchère mais contrairement à la cuisine
chinoise tu sais au moins quel animal on
a
alors pas beau monétaire à Paris et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu